les jardins de Versailles des tiennes
bien des mystères entre arts et histoire
passée et présents Nicolas Jacquet guide
le promeneur vers des lieux souvent
méconnus son dernier ouvrage intitulé
secret et curiosité des jardins de
Versailles se veut explicatif mais aussi
ludique l'idée
l'ouvrage avec dans sur chaque page une
explication un sens donné aux symbolique
au décor qui nous entoure et c'est
donner du sens aussi au niveau des
techniques qui sont employées en fait au
fur et à mesure des balades dans le
jardin de donner du sens et d'éveiller
les sens les jardins les bosses caser
les parcs révèlent leur nombreuses
symboliques désirées par Louis XIV et
orchestré par Le Nôtre Lebrun et Ardouin
Mansart des jardiniers qui ont su créer
un univers emprunt de poésie et
référence mythologiques célébrant la
puissance inégalable du roi soleil c'est
un endroit qu'avant tout un lieu de
poésie donc à partir de là on peut venir
et questionner et s'interroger en
permanence sur les symboliques les les
mythes et tout l'univers ferry qui nous
entoure et renouveler en permanence le
regard et ce qui fait que c'est un lieu
qui est ouvert au niveau de la lecture
et on peut venir 10 fois 30 fois et
redécouvrir de nouvelles choses et
rentrer dans l'histoire par une porte
qui est quand même assez poétique
à l'heure où l'on célèbre les 400 ans de
la naissance de Le Nôtre ce guide
accompagnera les visiteurs pour
découvrir redécouvrir ces domaines
chargés d'histoire